[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning amazon
founder jeff bezos
founded blue origin more than two
decades ago in hopes of
someday seeing earth from space well
tomorrow
he is all set to do exactly that on the
space flight company's rocket it's
called new shepard
he'll be joined by his brother mark go
mark veteran aviator wally funk
and recent high school graduate oliver
damon oliver by the way is from the
netherlands
so they're preparing for tomorrow's
launch near van horn texas
good morning oh look at you guys good
morning
god i'm so psyched i'm so excited for
you hi
you guys hi hi listen
who is right jeff jeff we're going to
start with you since you put this band
together i know this has been a
childhood dream for you
i wonder if it was everybody else's
dream i'd like to know that i know you
were ready
but how are you feeling about tomorrow
uh gail i'm i'm excited you know people
keep asking me if i'm nervous i'm not
really nervous
you're not started i jeff jeff you're
curious jeff you're not i want to know
what we're going to learn
wait jeff jeff back up in a second
you're not how is that possible jeff
i'm sitting here in new york and i'm
nervous how are you not nervous
none of us are nervous no we're excited
we've been training this vehicle is
ready this crew is ready this team is
amazing
uh we just feel really good about it
yeah wally we're all excited listen
we're all excited for all of you guys
oliver mark listen mark is a volunteer
firefighter so i know he likes
a little bit of danger in his life but
wally i keep thinking about your story
wally that you were 20 something
you were ready to go back in the day
that did not work out
and now you're being described as the
oldest person to go into space
which i think is very cool but i feel
like i'm 24.
that's great i love being here he's a
great man and
believe me gail wally can outrun all of
us we've been training you know
in the mercury 13 when they tested her
she was better than all the men and i
can guarantee you that's still true
today
yeah yes we're going to use wally's
energy to
launch this well you know i like that i
like i like that molly i like that
hey mark listen i know that this was
jeff's dream
and we were so touched when i saw the
video when he invited you go along to go
along
was it your dream too have my brother
seriously if you're
willing yeah i think that you know like
any little brother you uh you pick up on
what your
big brother loves and so certainly i
fell in love with space and
uh you know the the promise of it the
adventure of it and
i'm just so excited to be able to be
there and represent
my mom and dad and our sister christina
and supporting jeff and
realizing this lifelong dream it's just
a it's a real honor
it's a thrill and i'll tell you mark has
been a contributor to the blue origin
program from the very beginning
gail and he's been a contributor my
whole life and i couldn't have anybody
that i
would more want to go on this trip with
me yeah wally it's it's anthony
as gail alluded to you are by far the
most experienced person on this team and
actually started training what back in
nov in 1961
is that right have you got have you
given these guys
some advice on this
well yeah i just love the outdoors and
all the things that go with it and i've
built homes i've fixed cars and tractors
i've done everything there is to do
outdoors i was never
a little girl girl but i love being here
this is the greatest team that i could
ever be with and it's gonna go
it's gonna happen i've waited a long
time but i've dreamt
a lot of time to get to go up wow
wally is a role model for all of us on
grit and determination
and resilience everything she's
incredible
and oliver oliver you just joined the
team congrats to you
congrats you said you've been dreaming
about this since you were a little boy
oliver i'm still thinking you're a
little boy but this is good this is good
did you sleep last night yeah
did you sleep last night not that much
no no
so what are you thinking oliver
yeah i think the excitement just
overtakes the nervousness and
yeah can't wait just the time is taking
off now and
yeah just can't wait to go there when i
was 18 i was not going to space yeah
going to the prom
i was hoping for and i was hoping for a
date to the point
i was just hoping somebody asked me to
the problem now oliver you get to go
into space lucky you incredible
incredible um jeff are you all going to
wear space suits when you take off
tomorrow
no we'll be in these flight suits when
we take off tomorrow so with the
the cabin is pressurized it's redundant
we don't need to wear spacesuits and
we're going to be just like this jeff
tell us exactly what you're doing on
this mission
well we're going to go up it's a
suborbital
rocket it goes up into space
up uh we're in zero g
for about four minutes and we get to get
out of our seats unstrap
float around look at the thin limb of
the earth's atmosphere
people say that when they do that they
see how fragile
people who've been up astronauts earth
is so fragile you can see that
so i'm excited to see that i think we
all are so the views are going to be
terrific
the zero g will be an unusual experience
that you really can't get
in any good way on earth so we're
excited about it we'll
we'll have we'll we'll be able to tell
you more when we get back i know yeah
it's really it's really it's really
exciting i can't wait for you to come
back mark i think if i was on the flight
i would have to need a
pair of depends i know you don't need
that but if i was going
what i'd most be excited about is that
free floating in space the zero gravity
what are you most looking forward to
i i think that we're all really excited
to experience zero g and see what that's
going to be like i i can tell you gail
my
personally i can't wait for liftoff just
the the rumble of the engine and that
that acceleration and uh i just can't
wait to see what that's going to feel
like i'm
really excited about that wow i'm not
going to lie i'm going to be pretty
excited when i hear those parachutes
open too
yes yes yeah thank god for the parachute
wally what are you most looking forward
to
when i'm up in space and
able to do somersaults and tumble and do
anything that i've wanted to do i've had
practice at this
other uh areas on ground but the way
that they made the machinery
i could go do anything and that's what i
want i'm hoping to do that
i just i just want to get up there and
see the earth richard branson said this
just sit back and relax look out the
window
and enjoy the view do you all think
you're going to be able to do that sit
back relax i hear the window's really
big
and just enjoy the view can you do can
you really do that
i think i think so yeah i think so
i think that taking that moment of quiet
to do that is going to be an important
part of this journey gail
now you know um stephen colbert gave his
picture to richard branson to take up in
space would you like to get a picture of
all of us
i'll figure out a way to get it to you
jeff
you're welcome you can thank me later
jpeg
i'm i'm really excited thank you so much
thank you so much guys
cheering you on cheering you on all
right guys thank you so much thank you
bye jeff and mark bezos wally funk and
oliver damon
good luck good luck good luck can't wait
till you get back
we invite you to tune in to cbs news
tomorrow morning for special coverage of
new shepard's launch and landing
that's tomorrow at nine o'clock eastern
time 6 pacific